[Musik]
niehoff vladimir putin internationalen
sanktionen standhalten zu können hat der
russische präsident irgendwelche pläne
um den wirtschaftskrieg zu gewinnen mit
welchen mitteln will russland diesen
kampf führen warum stösst der rubel nach
der invasion ab gewann aber daraufhin
wieder an wert und ist nun sogar teurer
als vor dem krieg bedeutet dies dass der
kreml bereits dabei ist den
wirtschaftskrieg gegen den westen zu
gewinnen nur lebewesen politik zuschauer
in diesem video werden wir alle diese
fragen beantworten also lasst uns gleich
damit anfangen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
russlands krieg in der ukraine eine
grausame und rücksichtslose invasion
erweist sich nicht nur auf dem
schlachtfeld als großer albtraum sondern
auch weitaus größere wirtschaftliche
auswirkungen als erwartet dies gilt für
die ganze welt insbesondere jedoch für
die russische wirtschaft niemand in
moskau hat sich vorgestellt dass es 2022
so schlecht laufen würde was als
spezialeinsatz angekündigt wurde hat
sich zu einem intensiven
zermürbungskrieg entwickelte enormen
kosten in form von menschenleben
ausrüstung und ressourcen aller art
verursacht schätzungen zufolge kostet
russland allein die kriegsführung
zwischen einer halben und einer
milliarde dollar pro tag und in diesen
kosten sind die wirtschaftssanktionen
noch nicht eingerechnet jene
internationale reaktion von einem
kaliber dass sie jeden notfallplan des
kreml übertroffen hat
innerhalb weniger wochen nach der
invasion wurde russlands so eine art
paria so ein weitgehend isolierten land
zu dessen flugzeug ein großteil des
weltweiten luftraums gesperrt ist
international unternehmen in angst und
schrecken versetzt aus dem land fliehen
da ist weitgehend aus dem
internationalen finanzsystem
ausgeschlossen und in eine vielzahl von
handelsbeschränkungen belegt wurde
allein in moskau schon jetzt
zehntausende von arbeitsplätzen durch
den wegzug multinationaler unternehmen
gefährdet was sogar der kremltreue
bürgermeister der russischen hauptstadt
selbst bestätigt unseren schätzungen
zufolge sind etwa 200.000 menschen vom
verlust ihres arbeitsplatzes bedroht
sergej sobjanin bürgermeister moskaus
nun ja immerhin ist der
arbeitsplatzverlust nicht so schlimm wie
als kanonenfutter an der front verheizt
zu werden diese ehre bleibt den armen
schluckern aus den legeren regionen
vorbehalten die moskauer dürften weiter
in ihrer babbel am leben bleiben sie
werden jedoch abstriche machen müssen
wenn die aussichten für die russische
wirtschaft sind sehr düster geworden
[Musik]
da die sanktionen die importe gedrosselt
haben viele russische unternehmen ihre
geschäftstätigkeit aufgrund von
lieferengpässen einschränken müssen
hunderte westlicher unternehmen das land
verlassen haben tausende russen ihren
arbeitsplatz verlieren gerät die
russische wirtschaft ins stocken um euch
eine vorstellung davon zu geben nach
angaben der russischen zentralbank
selbst wird das russische bip bis 2022
um mindestens acht prozent sinken wobei
die prognosen der europäischen bank für
wiederaufbau und entwicklung in den zehn
prozent gehen und die der weltbank auf
über 11% und des institute of
international finance sogar auf 15
prozent wir sprechen hier von der
schlimmsten rezession in russland seit
anfang der 1990 er jahre und vergesst
bitte nicht das was ich hier erst um das
erste jahr handelt mittel und
langfristig erwarten viele analysten
dass es noch schlimmer kommen wird viel
viel schlimmer die besten schätzungen
die im moment sehe deuten darauf hin
dass die russische wirtschaft auf die
hälfte dessen reduziert wird was sie vor
der invasion war der liebste
stellvertretender nationaler
sicherheitsberater der usa es wird
weniger investitionen geben weniger
internationalen handel weniger
integration russlands in globale
wertschöpfungsketten und dies wird in
kombination mit den exodus von
fachkräften langfristig ein geringeres
produktivitätswachstum nach sich ziehen
wer firefox ex chefvolkswirt bei der
europäischen bank für wiederaufbau und
entwicklung aber dass du zu den fragen
zurückkehren die wir am anfang gestellt
haben wie auch wladimir putin den
internationalen sanktionen zu
widerstehen was ist sein plan um das zu
ergründen müssen wir zunächst einmal
genau wissen wie es russland derzeit
geht und was eigentlich putins gesamte
ära aus ökonomischer sicht am besten
charakterisiert also aufgepasst
ein neuer star für ein reich im
niedergang
bereits in mehreren videos hier auch
visuell politik haben wir dokumentiert
dass der fall der sowjetunion unter
übergang zur marktwirtschaft alles
andere als ein zuckerschlecken war
klasse misswirtschaft zügellose
korruption marode staatsfinanzen bis hin
zum staatsbankrott und schließlich eine
gigantische finanzkrise macht - 100 90er
jahre zu einem dramatischen jahr zählt
für russland zwischen 1990 und 98 ist
das reale pro kopf bip der russen zum
beispiel mehr als 40 prozent gesunken
und das gar von ausgangsniveau das auch
nicht besonders beeindruckend war nun
aus diesen ganzen debatte ist wladimir
putin hervorgegangen er wurde im jahr
2000 präsident und versprach einen
umfassenden reformprozess einzuleiten um
das land zu modernisieren und bekannt
dabei mit der wirtschaft kurz nach
seinem amtsantritt brachte putins
regierung den so genannten begriff plan
auf den weg einen plan der investoren
anlocken sollte
und wisst ihr was in gewisser weise war
dieser plan ein erfolg ja die korruption
blieb auf hohem niveau aber den
wirtschaftliche lage in russland konnte
sich deutlich verbessern die regierung
trägt die privatisierung und
deregulierung großer wirtschaftsbereiche
voran versucht internationale investoren
anzuziehen und führte eine pauschale
einkommensteuer von 30 prozent ein eine
pauschalsteuer mit der putin in der
international wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
viele punkte sammeln konnte doch putin
hatte auch verdammt viel glück
geopolitisches glück nur kurz nach
seinem amtsantritt schaltete chinas
wirtschaftsboom in den endgültigen turbo
modus und die kriegsabenteuer der bush
cheney gang im nahen osten verursachten
eine gravierende instabilität bei der
ölversorgung durch die zeitgleiche
kombination dieser beiden entwicklungen
gegen der ölpreis durch die decke und
blieb dort für viele jahre allein
zwischen 2002 und 2008 stiegen die
ölpreise fast um das vierfache etwas
besseres hätte putin und seiner clique
damals einfach nicht passieren können
sie konnten einen gigantischen reibach
machen und sogar ein paar von ihren
hunderten milliarden an petro dollars an
die russische bevölkerung durch
tröpfchen lassen nun ja wenn man bei
einem niveau von 2000 dollar
jahreseinkommen pro kopf anfängt kann
man auch mit nur einem kleinen bruchteil
der öl-milliarden zu viel freude beim
volk zeugen tatsache ist dass die
reformen zusammen mit dem daumen hoch
beim ölpreis das russische druck auf
einkommen von besagten 2000 dollar auf
einem höchststand von immerhin 16 1000
us dollar pro jahr in den 2010er jahren
ansteigen ließen was wir dabei nicht
vergessen dürfen die 16.000 dollar pro
jahr was ja auch kein großer reichtum
ist sind der durchschnittswert in dem
auch die millioneneinkommen der eliten
enthalten sind sie entsprechen nicht dem
was iwan normalverbraucher zur verfügung
stand aber allein dieser gewaltige
relative anstieg trieb putin popularität
innerhalb oder außerhalb russlands in
schwindelerregende höhen das problem war
jedoch dass ist mit all den schönen
reformen bald zu ende ging aufgrund der
gigantischen rohstoffeinnahmen verfügte
die russische regierung über so viele
ressourcen dass die einfach dachte
weitere reformen seien nicht mehr nötig
im gegenteil nach und nach drehte sich
die russische wirtschaft immer mehr nur
noch um den trend während die korruption
weiter in die höhe schoss und die neuen
reformpläne die vorgestellt wurden nie
in gang kam und so kam es wie es kommen
musste der herr hat russland gegeben und
er hat auch wieder genommen zusammen mit
dem eindruck der ölpreise im jahr 2015
und installationen nach der invasion auf
die krim hat sich das blatt gewendet
zieht euch einfach mal folgende grafik
wenn wir uns den anteil russlands am
weltweiten bip ansehen hat sich 20 jahre
nach der machtübernahme putins der
kreisky geschlossen russland steht
wieder am anfang heute aber noch dazu
mit einer katastrophalen demographie und
gewaltigen sanktionen ja die russen sind
heute reicher als im jahr 2000 aber
gegenüber den rest der welt hat sich
nichts geändert und im vergleich zu
anderen ländern die damals auch am boden
lagen sich jedoch in der zwischenzeit
wirtschaftlichen prinzipien konnten ist
russland in krasser weise zurück
gefallen vergleicht man die entwicklung
zum beispiel mit der des einstigen
russischen vasallenstaat polen wird erst
das ganze ausmaß von putins versagen
deutlich war die russische
volkswirtschaft im jahr 2014 noch vier
mal so groß wie die polen das etwa auch
dem verhältnis der einwohnerzahlen
entspricht so erreichte polens
wirtschaftsleistung sieben jahre später
bereits 40 prozent der russlands und
durfte nach dem kriegs einbruch die 50
prozent marke gerissen haben es ist
daher wenn man noch das weitere
wachstumspotenzial polens berücksichtigt
durchaus realistisch zu erwarten dass
die größe der wirtschaft russlands bald
der polens entsprechenden oder sogar
kleiner sein wird und was noch schlimmer
ist es gibt keinerlei
zukunftsperspektive
nicht nur weil die russische bevölkerung
oder nennenswerte ersparnisse und
produktivitäts puffer verreist und
ausstirbt das was von der russischen
wirtschaft übrig bleibt das zunehmend
von großen ineffizienten korrupten
konzernen beherrscht der tätigkeit vor
allem von der gunst der regierung
abhängt das ist der grund warum russland
zum beispiel nur noch rohstoffe
exportiert der einzig nenneswerte
exportsektor den russland mit einer
gewissen werk schöpfung noch mithalten
konnte die rüstungsindustrie dürfte nach
der desaströsen negativen werbekampagne
in der ukraine nun auch in der
versenkung verschwinden in diesem
ultimativen test dürfte die ganze welt
durch die katastrophale performance des
russischen militärs endgültig zeuge der
enormen auswirkungen der korruption und
misswirtschaft auf die qualität
russische rüstungsprojekte werden aber
darüber haben wir schon in unserem
letzten video gesprochen wie dem auch
sei tatsache ist dass mit den sanktionen
die nach dem angriff auf die ukraine
verhängt wurden die dinge noch viel viel
schlimmer werden könnten denn selbst
wenn jetzt sofort der krieg in der
ukraine zu ende gehen sollte fängt für
russland der kampf ums wirtschaftliche
überleben erst richtig an und wie ihr
sehen könnt scheint russland nicht
gerade in bester verfassung in diese
entscheidende schlacht zu wählen die
russische wirtschaft ist von korruption
durchsetzt die unternehmen sind nicht
nur über der förderung von rohstoffen
sehr ineffizient und sowohl der konsum
als auch die produktion vor ort sind
stark von internationalen lieferketten
abhängig was putin vielleicht am besten
hingekriegt hat war die ausgaben und die
staatsverschuldung in schach zu halten
vor allem nach der invasion der krämer
als der kreml nach der ersten runde der
sanktionen betrifft dass ein gesunder
staatshaushalt und viele internationale
reserve notwendig waren um den
wirtschaftskrieg zu führen
im jahr 2014 begann die russische
regierung einen notfallplan zu
entwickeln der nun vollständig umgesetzt
werden muss ein plan in eine frau eine
schlüsselrolle spielt elvira nabiullina
ja okay ich weise sie hatten nicht das
typische gesicht eines cartoon
bösewichts aber diese frau führt
tatsächlich die großoffensive an mit der
putin auf den wirtschaftskrieg die die
verbündeten russland angesiedelt haben
zu gewinnen oder zumindest so
widerstehen und wie sieht das zu tun
gedenkt sehen uns jetzt genau an
die frau die den rubel wieder rollen
lässt
den krieg in der ukraine gewinnen und
einen wirtschaftlichen zusammenbruch
vermeiden das sind die beiden ziele
welche die russische regierung zu ihren
obersten prioritäten erklärt hat und
elvira nabiullina die chefin der
russischen zentralbank ist eine der
schlüsselfiguren bei der erreichung des
zweiten ziels
sie steht damit in ihrer bedeutung die
kuren wie sergej schoigu oder war leere
kassen oft nichts nach im gegenteil wird
putin ist dies sogar noch wichtiger und
geradezu unersetzlich nabiullina die aus
den marktwirtschaftlichen und pro
demokratischen kreisen russland stammt
ist seit der machtübernahme putins eine
seiner engsten vertrauten zunächst was
ich stellvertretende ministerin für
wirtschaftliche entwicklung und handel
im jahr 2007 sollte sie zur ministerin
das ganze sourcecode förder und führte
es bis 2012 danach war die chef berater
des präsidenten für wirtschaftliche
angelegenheiten unserer 2013 die chefin
der zentralbank diese funktion übt sich
übrigens mit viel mehr autorität aus als
die meisten ihre internationalen
kollegen denn juli nach kontrolliert
alles finanzen geldpolitik die
versicherungswirtschaft investmentfonds
banken staatsreserven und noch viel mehr
wir fühlen uns bereich ist sie die
wahrscheinlich wichtigste persönlichkeit
des ganzen landes und auch die russische
managerin mit dem höchsten
internationalen ansehen jahrelang war es
jetzt hier den hobel zu stabilisieren
und die inflation zu bekämpfen das tat
sie mit eiserner hand sie schloss 500
bank hob die zinssätze weit über den
internationalen setzte an und
liberalisierte die landeswährung
russlands integration in die
internationale wirtschaft zu fördern nun
was sie auch kräftig gefördert hat war
die verstaatlichung von fast 70 prozent
des russischen bankensystems aber das
ist eine andere geschichte tatsache ist
dass ich mit dem angriff russlands auf
die ukraine auch nach bio lenas ziele
vollkommen verändert haben
jahrelang hat die zentralbank alles
getan um russlands zu helfen sich weiter
in die weltwirtschaft integriert dann am
24 februar musste sie plötzlich das
gegenteil tun tatsache ist dass ab juli
nach ihrem chef putin mit kurz nach
dessen angriffsbefehl ihren rücktritt
angeboten hat doch dieser lehnte dankend
ab verlängerte ihr engagement prompt auf
eine dritte amtszeit und verliere
gleichzeitig weitere vollmachten sie ist
jetzt auch noch für die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung russlands verantwortlich ja
war ein ganz schöner bumerang dieses
rücktritts gesuchten und nabiullina ist
für diese herkulesaufgabe manche sagen
sogar himmelfahrtskommando wahrlich
nicht zu beneiden aber diese geniale
frau als gestandene experten schon öfter
überrascht was hat sie also jetzt in
petto nun sperrt eure lauscher auf jetzt
geht's ans eingemachte und nabiullina
dort ein auge trocken lassen
[Musik]
die wirtschaftliche gegenoffensive des
kreml im
[Musik]
wesentlichen kann der russische
gegenangriff auf die sanktionen des
westens in zwei große aktionsbereiche
von grundlegend unterschiedlichen
charakter unterteilt werden auf der
einen seite kurzfristige maßnahmen um
den sofortigen absturz abzufangen und
auf der anderen eine langfristige
strategie und die russische wirtschaft
in den kommenden monaten und sogar
jahren widerstandsfähig zu machen falls
die strafmaßnahmen über einen längeren
zeitraum andauern sollten und davon ist
auszugehen in diesem sinne hat die
russische regierung bereits 2014 als
erstes ihre devisenreserven aufgestockt
das gewicht von vermögenswerten die den
chinesischen yuan rund gold erhöht und
möglicherweise einen großen teil davon
sogar gut versteckt ja das ist richtig
die russische zentralbank wird
verdächtigt dutzende von milliarden
dollar auf zwielichtigen offshore konten
versteckt zu haben um internationalen
sanktionen zu entgehen die rede ist von
bis zu 80 milliarden dollar in
us-staatsanleihen die über ein komplexes
und intransparentes beteiligungsfirmen
geflecht auf den cayman inseln oder
sogar in belgien versteckt sind wohl
euroclear der größten
vermögensverwaltungsgesellschaften der
welt ihren sitz hat
[Musik]
es gibt auch spekulationen dass die
russische zentralbank in der lage waren
30 milliarden dollar in ihren eigenen
dressuren anzuhäufen der punkt ist dass
diese versteckten reserven der
russischen regierung die möglichkeit
gibt um die sanktionen des westens zu
unterlaufen und weiterhin auf den
internationalen märkten zu agieren ohne
dass dies jemand offiziellen akt so
können sie zum beispiel russlands
auslandsschulden zu einem bruchteil
ihres wertes aufkaufen so wichtige
importe oder investitionen bezahlen und
vor allem eines betreiben massive kurs
kosmetik denn für die machthaber im
kreml ist der kurs des vogel ein
ausgezeichnetes propaganda instrument
mit dem sie der eigenen bevölkerung
demonstrieren können dass die sanktionen
keine wirkung haben auch wenn die
wirtschaft im land eigentlich den bach
runtergeht dazu müssen sie nur den kurs
nach oben manipulieren koste es was es
wolle
tja aber wie genau geht das nun nachdem
die internationalen sanktionen
beschlossen waren stürzte der rubel ab
wie eines zu keine ungewollten begegnung
mit einer rakete kurz darauf reagierte
die russische zentralbank mit einem
notfall paket das eine zinserhöhung auf
zunächst sagenhafte 20 später noch immer
beachtliche 17 prozent beinhaltete sowie
die einführung strenger
kapitalkontrollen
so wurden zum beispiel abhebungen von
fremdwährungen von konten eingeschränkt
eine steuer wird in einigen fällen sogar
über gegen das verbot den kauf von
fremdwährungen eingeführt und
exportierende unternehmen wurden
verpflichtet 80 prozent ihrer
ausländischen einnahmen in noble so
tauschen außerdem wurden sich
verpflichtet diese auslands erlöse nach
russland zu überweisen und im lande zu
belassen internationale investoren war
es untersagt ihre position an der
moskauer börse zu liquidieren oder
dividenden oder zinszahlungen zu
erhalten am 9 märz hat die russische
regierung außerdem die steuer auf den
kauf von edelmetallen abgeschafft damit
die russen für ihre ersparnisse liebe
inländisches goldstadt dollar pfund oder
euro kaufen nach angaben des bankers
sich die nachfrage nach gold in ersten
märzwochen deswegen vervierfacht die
dafür aufgebrachten rubel landeten also
nicht auf dem devisenmarkt und konnten
so den rubel kurs in dollar und euro
nicht drücken aber das ziel all dieser
maßnahmen war es die kapitalflucht zu
verhindern um den rubel kurs gegenüber
ausländischen währungen durch kurs
kosmetik zu stützen und zwar wie gesagt
um jeden preis wie hoch dieser preis ist
werden wir gleich sehen denn auf den
ersten blick sieht ist ja so aus als
wäre es vom nabu julina durchaus
gelungen den fall aufzuhalten sogar so
sehr dass ein kurs an diesem alter höher
steht als vor dem krieg und viele fragen
sich nun wie kann das denn überhaupt
sein spiegelt die kuss erholung beim
rubel den erfolg der russischen
wirtschaft im kampf gegen die sanktionen
wieder nun nicht im geringsten das wäre
der fall wenn es sich um einen freien
markt handeln würde doch davon kann nun
keine rede mehr sein der rubel ist
aufgrund der massiven durch russland
betrieben interventionen verzerrungen
und beschränkungen auf der
internationalen bühne außer in
bestimmten spezialfällen praktisch
nutzlos geworden
denn überlegt mal eine sekunde könnt ihr
irgendeinen anderen indikator außer des
rubel kurses benennen der darauf
hinweisen würden dass die russische
wirtschaft jetzt die gleichen oder gar
bessere aussichten hat als mitte februar
vor beginn der invasion tja diese krasse
anomalie es zeigt dass hier irgendwas
verdammt faul ist der starke hobel also
ziemlich wenig mit der russischen
wirtschaftskraft zu tun oder damit dass
es den russen in zukunft besser gehen
wird er beruht auf massiven
interventionen und den gleichzeitigen
zusammentreffen gleich mehrere effekte
die zu einer übertreibung führen
vergesst bitte nicht dass man auch wo
geratenen märkte auch von einem extrem
ins andere schwanken da sich zunächst
alle teilnehmer zuerst auf die eine also
auf die angebote oder nachfrageseite
stürzen und daraufhin wieder auf die
andere ich werde euch gleich erklären
woraus diese effekte zur zeit bestehen
und wie sie sich entwickeln werden die
russische regierung kündigte an für ihre
rohstoffexporte nur noch zahlungen in
rhode zu akzeptieren und einige abnehmer
wenn auch nicht die großen fügten sich
diesem diktat da der obel keine währung
ist in der sonst viel gehandelt wird und
auch die kapitalmarkt kontrolle in
russland dazu beigetragen haben dass
sich der ohnehin engen rubel markt auf
der angebotsseite noch weiter verengt
würde diese erzwungene rubel nachfrage
natürlich zu einem starken
ungleichgewicht und hobel mangel dieser
sondereffekt wird sich nicht endlos
aufrechterhalten lassen und deswegen für
putins währung chefin ab juli einen
weiteren kniff einer die zentralbank
legt eine festen preis für gold käufer
fest 5000 rubel pro gramm gold und die
frage ist was das alles eigentlich soll
nun ab juli geht es darum das angebot
der zentralbahn rubel unbedingt knapp zu
halten und da ist für regierung und
große multinationale unternehmen wegen
des knappen angebots heutzutage nicht so
einfach ist ein robl zu kommen sollen
sie ihre käufe mit gold bezahlen dieses
wird dann zu dem von der zentralbank
festgelegten preis in rubel getauscht
wurden im gegensatz zu dem was viele
medien berichten und geht es den russen
nicht darum zum goldstandard
zurückzukehren weil die russische
währung ohnehin nicht konvertibel sein
wird vielmehr geht es darum den rubel
kurs noch stärker zu polieren die
russischen gold reserven zu erhöhen und
ganz wichtig dass petrodollars system
anzugreifen das heißt den kauf von erdöl
mit der währung von andersen dies gilt
als einer der eckpfeiler des dollar als
leitwährung eine der usa die länder wie
china ebenfalls zu untergraben versuchen
aber über diesen ambitionierten plan der
ist wirklich in sich hat werden wir bald
ein eigenes video drehen ihr dürft euch
also schon freuen trotzdem die wette
gegen den dollar als leitwährung ist
sehr riskant und nur wenn sie aufgeht
könnte russland wirklich profitieren
scheitert sie mit russland am ende mit
weniger devisen da stehen mit denen ist
auf dem internationalen markt waren
kaufen könnte waren welche von seiner
industrie dringend benötigt werden eine
weitere galgenfrist erhielt putin ja
vorerst durch den enormen anstieg der
rohstoffpreise diese schossen aufgrund
des kriegs und sanktions schocks in die
höhe obwohl ist ja noch nicht zu
wirklichen rohstoff engpässen in der
realwirtschaft gekommen war
die preissteigerung warum hauptsächlich
auf spekulativen wetten händler decken
sich noch schnell mit kontrakten auf
zukünftige lieferungen ein natürlich
auch punkt und hoffen diese dann mit
gewinn verkaufen zu können die frage ist
wird ihre spekulation aufgehen denn die
zinserhöhung der us notenbank und das
lockdown gebeutelte chinesische
wirtschaftswachstum dürften mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit eher zu einem
konjunktureinbruch und damit eine
sinkende nachfrage nach erdöl und
anderen rohstoffen führen die preis
explosion von der moskauer in den
vergangenen zwei monaten gut profitieren
konnte ist also eher durch einen effekt
zu erklären der mit denen hamsterkäufen
vergleichbar ist bei denen sich leute
mit klopapier und speiseöl eindecken und
zwar viel mehr als sie brauchen werden
denn das dicke ende kommt eben sobald
die hamster weg bleiben beziehungsweise
ihre oft mit immer teurer werdenden
krediten finanzierten vorräte wieder auf
den markt werfen müssen dann brechen die
preise wieder ein und treffen einen
russland und dem sich sein großkunde
europa in der zwischenzeit dann immer
mehr unabhängig gemacht haben wird die
nachfrage wird dann also noch weiter
einbrechen und mit ihr auch die
abnahmepreise wobei russland zurzeit
seine sowieso schon mit sehr starken
abschlägen gegenüber dem weltmarktpreis
verkaufen muss es aber einen immer
kleineren kreis von käufern angewiesen
ist und diese ihre starke position
selbstverständlich ausnutzen auf jeden
fall ist es die kombination all dieser
effekte die sich nur auf einer seite
auswirken strenge kapitalkontrollen der
einbruch der importe nach russland der
umtausch zwang zum googeln export und
den gestiegenen rohstoffpreise welche
dazu geführt hat rubel im ersten april
so stark gestiegen ist dass er seinen
wert von vor der invasion sogar
übertreffen konnte
[Musik]
das problem daran natürlich hat eine
währung auf der so viele intervention
lasten nicht viel langfristigen wert und
schon gar nicht verhindert diese
oberflächliche kuss kosmetik die
restlichen auswirkungen auf die
volkswirtschaft des landes denke daran
dass der rubel der sowjetunion der
praktisch nichts wert war ein
offiziellen wechselkurs von 0,6 jubel
für 1 dollar hatte und die sowjetunion
war sicherlich nicht als konkurrenz
pflege exportmacht bekannt wenn man zb
aufhört wichtige komponenten aus dem
ausland zu importieren sinkt zwar die
inlandsnachfrage nach dollar aber es
kann passieren dass viele unternehmen im
land nicht mehr produzieren können oder
sogar zusammenbrechen natürlich führt
eine solche aufwertung der landeswährung
in verbindung mit erdrückend hohen
zinsen dazu dass die produzierende
exportwirtschaft des landes jegliche
wettbewerbsfähigkeit gegenüber dem
ausland verliert kurzfristig wird durch
diese politik als der währungskurs
aufpoliert langfristig erstickt putin
aber jenen rest wertschöpfenden
verarbeitenden gewerbes den es in
russland bisher noch gibt an eine
zukunft deutschlands als global
konkurrenzfähige diversifiziert und
komplexe exportnation ist es so
überhaupt nicht mehr zu denken alle
ressourcen der wirtschaft vom kapital
über know-how bis hin zu fachkräften und
netzwerkeffekte dann noch weiter voll
auf den export von bodenschätzen
konzentriert wo durch russland wieder
allen schwankungen der rohstoffpreise
auf dem weltmarkt ausgesetzt sein wird
punkten mit diesen wirtschaftskurs quasi
den absoluten anti erdogan letzterer
versucht ja mit niedrigen zinsen und
einer schwachen türkischen lehrer sein
land zu einer industriellen exportmacht
zu machen wir haben darüber ein video
gemacht denn beide extreme sind
schädlich ihnen steht die balance sie
führen die wirtschaft eines landes auf
einen einseitigen kurs vorbei erdogan
gegenüber putin nur und geradezu als
wirtschaftskrimi da steht nun ja wie dem
auch sei all diese maßnahmen sind nur
für einen kurzen zeitraum sinnvoll und
die frage ist was die russische
regierung zu tun gedenkt wenn sich die
situation über jahre hinzieht
man muss bedenken die ersten beiden
monate des aktion werden nicht
repräsentativ sein für die weitere
entwicklung nun putin und julia haben da
noch ein paar weitere kniffe parat die
russische regierung scheint eine
strategie vorzubereiten und russische
aktien und vermögenswerte ausländische
investoren aufzukaufen natürlich unter
sehr hohen abschlägen ihre idee ist eine
gruppe von nationalen champions zu
schaffen große unternehmen die praktisch
alles übernehmen würden im grunde wollen
sie also genau jene strategie der
wirtschaftlichen kontrolle weiter
ausbauen die putins regierung in den
letzten jahren sowieso schon verfolgt
hat einige dieser unternehmen sollen
dann auch schon merkt notiert werden wo
sie geld von investoren aus weniger
feindseligen ländern aufnehmen können
aus ländern wie china oder den petri
monarchin am persischen golf ich frage
mich allerdings ob diese ihr geld
wirklich in unternehmen investieren
werden die nach einem muster gestrickt
sind dass sich in der vergangenheit als
wenig leistungsfähig und er ist erwiesen
hat nach einer blaupause gemäß der die
jetzige struktur der russischen
rüstungsindustrie entworfen wurde welche
ja gerade im krieg nun bewiesen hat dass
sie nichts auf die reihe bekommt wir
haben darüber ausführlich im vorigen
video gesprochen gut bleibt dem kreml
noch eine letzte hoffnung seine
wirtschaft doch noch irgendwie auf
battle zu können die bereits angekündigt
wird die politik der in prostitution in
voller breite ausgerollt und mit allen
kräften unterstützt das heißt zb
einheimische unternehmen mit günstigen
krediten versorgt auf diese weise soll
es firmen die direkt produkte herstellen
die von den sanktionen betroffen sind
bisher aus dem aus reduziert wurden
nicht unter den horrenden zinsen leiden
müssen
[Musik]
das problem dabei selbst wenn ein
gewisser grad an substitution gelingen
sollte ist auf einem der abgeschotteten
und schrumpfenden markt mit nichts
anderes als effizienten prozessen und
minderwertiger qualität zu verrechnen
aber dies wäre ja beileibe nichts neues
als teil dieser strategie vertraue putin
und nabiullina schließlich darauf dass
länder wie china und indien am ende die
russischen wirtschaft retten könnten und
sie hoffen sogar dass die sanktionen
nicht ausgeweitet oder bald sogar
zurückgefahren werden moskau hofft
darauf dass die globalisierung weiter
läuft und dass die welt nicht bereit
sein wird auf ihre rohstoffe zu
verzichten us geheimdienste gehen
bereits davon aus dass putin auf
nachlassende entschlossenheit des besten
setzt
das also meine lieben zuschauer ist
putins plan sich von den westlichen
volkswirtschaften abkapseln seine
währung mit ball stärken inländische
vermögenswerte zurückgewinnen und darauf
vertrauen dass china indien und andere
ähnliche länder als ausreichende
rettungsanker fungieren können um den
sturm zu überstehen
natürlich könnte das leichter gesagt als
getan sein im moment sieht es überhaupt
nicht danach aus dass putins plan erfolg
haben wird russland ist zunehmend von
der weltwirtschaft isoliert wollen wir
euch hier auf visuelle politik vor
kurzem einen eigenen video gezeigt haben
wird ihnen nicht mal china unter die
arme greifen die wirkliche auswirkungen
dann der erst spüren wenn die
lieferketten und produktionslinien
zusammenbrechen das meiste was in
russland produziert wird hängt von
komponenten aus dem besten ab und ohne
diese teile wird die arbeit stillstehen
in automobilfabriken bei
offshore-bohrungen in der luftfahrt und
so weiter aber auch hier können wir
nicht behaupten dass uns das sonderlich
überrascht putins pläne in sachen
wirtschaft haben schon lange nicht mehr
besonders gut funktioniert in den
letzten jahren ist es mit der russischen
wirtschaft immer weiter abwärts gegangen
das russische pro kopf einkommen ist von
seinem höchststand von einst 16.000 us
dollar binnen zehn jahren auf etwa
12.000 us dollar gesunken da lag es
zumindest noch kurz vor der invasion in
der ukraine jetzt angesichts der
sanktionen deutet alles darauf hin dass
es deutlich unter 10.000 dollar fallen
wird das wäre ein rückgang von fast 50%
seit den putin den initialen reformkurs
beiseite schob und anträgen seine er
nationalistische und despotische agenda
schritt für schritt umzusetzen
[Musik]
alles deutet darauf hin dass die russen
ihre aggressionen gegen die ukraine
teuer bezahlen werden einen großen teil
ihrer devisenreserven haben sie bereits
verloren hunderte von milliarden dollar
für welche sieht die ganzen jahre zuvor
rohstoffe in alle welt geliefert haben
sind nun ein freuen und werden wohl für
reparationszahlungen an die ukraine
verwandt und dies wird erst der anfang
sein die jagd nach großen vermögen hat
eigentlich erst gold aber über diese
pläne und das spannende thema wer den
wiederaufbau der ukraine bezahlen wird
werden wir bald ein eigenes video
herausbringen vergesst also bitte nicht
das abo und ganz wichtig das glöckchen
um es ja nicht zu verpassen und jetzt
kommen die immer eure hausaufgaben
glaubt ihr dass die russische wirtschaft
ist schaffen wird die internationalen
sanktionen zu umgehen kann der vom
westen entfesselte wirtschaftskrieg dass
putin regime zu fall bringen werden die
sanktionen lange genug andauern sollten
die verbündeten ländern ihre strafen
gegen russland noch verschärfen die
antworten sind wir immer bis mitternacht
im kommentarbereich abzugeben eine
benotung findet nicht statt denn hier
lernen wir für uns selbst nicht für eine
billige belohnung ich hoffe also dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat er
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt fast
jahr gibt es mit einlassen oder freunde
unvergessliches aber mit glöckchen und
kann in unseren videos müssen verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit der bus
hält dieses projekt weiterzuführen in
peking dazu findet ihr in der
beschreibung oder dem video was gut und
bis bald